I'm still alive god damn it god bless
you mr. Reese god bless your soul you
know when it looked like old hopes was
lost everyone was tweeting about all the
mass media is to celebrating yes this
Indian company anything except PewDiePie
basically Oh mr. B's you saved my life
I already metal passed me when this
video goes out I have one final thing
though
I have one last resort that I have not
used yet okay
because I haven't had to use it yet an
Indian channel will soon overtake Peter
pine to become most subscribed on
YouTube you're saying a million dollar
company which had thousands of employees
to reach it releases five to ten videos
a day have their ads everywhere only
followed by people who understands Hindi
it's up against a self-made guy who came
at this point by starting making videos
at home has to be number one youtuber
for five to six years house following
from all around the world and puts a lot
of a lot of effort ok that's a bit of a
stretch and even many of them gets
copyrights that is not a stretch he
doesn't care but will making videos with
beds and they'll always be number one to
his fans that is so sweet it's
interesting how many people just hate me
so much that they'll literally celebrate
anyone taking over bunch of crybabies
well you can keep crying for a few more
days cuz we're still in it mr. B's
impact yeah it was crazy
obviously what do I have now I almost
have 60 it's working when all hope
thought it was last second Lord of the
Rings when that part happens you know
you know what I mean come on Pentagon
hexagon octagon all revenue gone what
can I say I've learned from my mistakes
because of my moral code and no other
reasons look at this you guys are really
trying hard now aren't you posting this
again just reminded that we are winning
the entire war because T series barely
have any followers on Twitter I don't
get it though the whole thing is so
confusing to me you may have won the
battle but not the war they haven't won
yet
working with SpaceX and Tesla
Meem review with PewDiePie come on Ilan
we need your help please leave us please
hey little mustache stop sending me this
so many fake tweets now I feel like this
is fake too people just won't let go
hey look it's another fake tweet how
original
okay fine we'll really scare PewDiePie
season 2 but am I gonna alright it's ten
of manga I was like what reference is
that I'm getting old guys I'm getting
too old for memes imagine writing
something and not being able to erase it
that just gave me a thought like what
about when you're 80 years old and some
someone throws you know because memes
are all about it being obscure and
people not really getting it you're 80
and someone hits you up with a Ugandan
knuckles and just one person's like hell
yeah
or a troll face trophies the ancient the
ancient symbol of trolling lib toss back
in my day imagine writing something and
not being able to erase it this post was
made by pencil gang pencil gang is also
sponsoring this video
thank you very much pencil game pencil
gang has decided to join our cause
against t-series domo arigato pencil
gang Felix do you think your thoughts in
English or in Swedish I don't know do
you ever think what your thoughts are no
I don't think about it probably English
sometimes I speak a lot during my sleep
and Marsalis as I speak in Swedish so I
guess there's a there's a parse we -
part of me still in there kicking and
screaming he bought every billboard in
my city for this okay if you haven't
watched the video you get yet check it
out they get a description god bless you
mr. B's
now if anyone else will stand up if any
other youtubers will stand up in this
fight which side of war will you be on
History Channel here's something I made
for Puetz hope you you fellow 9 year
olds like it
that is pretty epic I must say except
they never accepted my challenge you
have no idea with my Twitter fetus right
now okay you don't even want to know why
the f you crying so damn loud so proud
of myself for taking a big step today
and
following her heart goodbye YouTube can
we get a F in the chat you know she
could have given me the channel at least
so I could be t-series but you know I
guess I gotta be supportive Felix don't
forget to make the video that is 5
minutes slow down 2x to make it 10
minutes why make it 5 minutes when I can
make a 10 minute video 20 minutes I
wonder if I get more watch time that way
could that be like I wake because
YouTube is all about watch time the more
watch time you have the better so maybe
if I do that let's do it on this video
meme review when midnight
hey tweet that isn't actually fake how
about that I'm still waiting in line we
need your help George tasks it that you
on Chad I know he knows what that means
a goddamn weave I've seen HUS videos
David we will be going to that what
what's a PewDiePie and why did you tell
your grandpa to subscribe to him I'm
doing my part when you realize PewDiePie
won't be the first youtuber to hit 69
million subscribers come on guys we have
a goal we have a mission please it's the
only thing I'll ever ask you guys for
except constantly asking begging for
life subscribers and all that well
please guys it's the only time I ever
asked for anything I could buy YouTube
delete sir this is where the good ideas
come really escape it if I season 2 but
I'm I got it damn we were so close I
almost thought this tweet was real
incredible I was planning to make a
video where I rate other people's
apologies do it I already did it
check it out it was pretty epic I wish I
could have brought in more apology
videos they just took so long I don't
know why well I got married in a
pewdiepie shirt today look at that
you're virgins congratulations even 9
year olds can manage to find a love for
their lives
oh you got to do is really buy the merch
I've been saying this for so long that's
honestly amazing thank you very much I'm
honored honestly though the mean review
merch was that the most supported
Murchie ball and that I've ever
and I just want to say thank you very
much for for everyone that got it I
really really appreciate it felix has to
get married in a shirt of you now just
where the deaf child Felix just marry my
wife Felix okay moving on he protect he
attack but most importantly he is the
best
happy birthday Felix this is so sweet
except it's not my birthday anymore you
idiot logan paul pretended to be
colorblind faked a reaction to seeing
colors taste dead rants and made fun of
a real dead body given a high-budget
sequel to his youtube movie pewdiepie
made one joke well it wasn't really one
joke let's get really here yes yeah it
was one it was one joke it was one joke
and had his show canceled because
someone called him it's okay because
it's vegan now that's true
petition for Felix to make a cardboard
Elin so he will actually co-host me
review pretty good idea thank you
Elon Musk dr. Phil Ben Shapiro being
ready to host meme review come up come
up break anyone so proud of myself for
taking the big step today poor learning
hard I hope my tie finds what she's
looking for in life and I wish her good
luck for the future also hope t-series
releases a similar video soon one can
only dream images you can hear I want
him to do a part two like all of them I
try to reach out to the kid
he wouldn't reply but I know he
commented on one of my videos I know
you're listening please get all your
friends I beg you get all your friends
and do okay that would be epic
PewDiePie fans that are still not in the
subreddit when will you say honestly
that you're doing your part you can't
look at afterwards and go oh I wish
things were different
okay you can't pull a Swede and be like
oh sorry mr. Hitler summer please go
country up ah we should have done
something you can't do that this is not
it that is it that looks like me is that
that
kid Tim I wasn't right I was right
getting an F in tests realizing teachers
were just trying to pay respect
this is showed nice YouTube can you give
me money to pay for rent to pay for rent
yes
actually by it's a useless belt like a
boss I still have the belt
if anyone can let me know how to use it
that would be great thank you problems
of the rich people huh this is what I've
been saying all along yeah the more
money nothing hits me like an Italian
pasta me mamma mia pizzeria not even
their Chi might see yet
imagine having to click to subscribe
this post was made by t-series gang oh
the Last Supper yep hello I'm Pierce and
I'm here to talk about serious topics
okay that's amazing
skull Dino or did you make this I gotta
make sure yeah it is oh damn he's made a
lot of that damn that's awesome thank
you very much that's really cool yeah I
don't even know what my channel this
anymore
PewDiePie candies simple chocolate can
you do this lemon candy in green wrapper
okay PewDiePie claps oh my god you like
your loose cookies you eat you loose
this is such good ideas normal times too
baby
oh yeah hope you guys enjoyed this video
in times two you can switch that off now
if you feel like it tamasha like if you
enjoyed this video just kidding
subscribe subscribe goddammit this is
our last chance listen up you stupid
kids I had enough of you okay I'm not
gonna pretend pretend I like you because
I know I care one thing and one thing
only to get to 69 million before that
goddamn you know what it doesn't matter
you know what to do there will be no
epic brofist that's right I'm retracting
all the profits until these deed is done
now you have a true incentive now you
have a true challenge now you have
something to with a burning passion to
truly fight for that go forth dammit
what are you still doing here
get the Frick out bye
[Music]